Picture yourself five years ago. Same
dreams, different year. Same goals,
different month. Plot twist. You're not
here by accident. The brutal truth.
You're not stuck because you lack
motivation. You're stuck because you're
trying to make 47 different choices
instead of the one that matters. Winners
make one choice. Losers make excuses.
Here's the math nobody teaches. More
choices equals less progress. It's like
trying to ride 12 horses at once. While
you're collecting goals, they're
collecting results. What if 80% of your
transformation comes from one decision?
This isn't minimalism. It's mathematics.
Someone decided to finally write that
book. Someone decided to leave that
toxic job. One choice created a cascade.
Your future self is watching you right
now.
They're either thanking you or writing
you out of their will. The next 5 years
will pass anyway. They can pass with you
wondering or with you becoming. Your one
choice is waiting. The time is now.